- We are back, and it's
our gutsy hour, everybody.
And our next guest is
a very talented actor
and an amazing musician.
He does it all.
He's one of the bestselling Latin artists
out there right now.
He is nominated this year
for Best Latin Album at the Grammys,
which is incredible.
(audience cheers)
His latest album is called "Don Juan".
You can check it out
wherever you get your music.
Say hello to Maluma.
(audience cheering)
- Oh no, I was kidding, I was kidding.
- I know, I know, I was like,
it gets a little scary here.
- In case you guys
forget a Christmas tree.
- Yes.
I love it.
Green is my favorite color, Maluma.
- Oh really?
- Yes.
- Well, mine is purple,
but for today it's red.
- Yeah.
So anyway, I have to say,
what's your gutsiest moment
you feel like in life?
- Well, actually I brought a picture.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, I need to show you guys, yeah.
- Okay.
- Now in this picture is
totally pink, you see?
It's not the gutsy moment though.
- It's not.
- No, no, no, no.
This was the first time that
I went on tour after COVID,
and I was the first Latino artist,
actually to say that I wanted
to tour again after COVID.
It was pretty dangerous.
But it was like the pioneer
after COVID hit so bad.
So I felt like, okay, I need to.
- No, that is a gutsy moment.
- Yeah.
- I need to, yeah, I need to do it.
And after that, I saw all my colleagues
doing it at the same time.
So that was like pretty
nice to be the first artist.
- That's really brave,
'cause people were getting a lot of
like, "Ugh, should we do it?
Should we not do it?"
It was very scary.
- Yeah, yeah.
Of course, we did it in
a pretty responsible way.
- Yeah.
- Of course.
Because it was kind of tough.
It was 2019, you know? So, but
it was a great, a great tour.
All the arenas were sold out, thank God.
So it was beautiful.
- Yeah.
Well, congratulations.
You're nominated for another Grammy.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] That's so exciting.
- [Maluma] Thank you.
- I'm gonna tell you, my
first Grammys I ever went to
is actually the Latin Grammys.
It was my first one.
I did a duet and they asked me to sing
and I was like, sure.
- No way.
- But I love the American Grammy.
I love the English Grammys,
but the Latin Grammys
were so great.
They were so passionate and
so, I love the performances.
- [Maluma] Thank you.
- It was a really wonderful experience.
- Thank you.
You know that I've never been
performing at the Grammys,
like the American Grammys.
I only been performing in Latin Grammys,
but we're waiting for this opportunity
because this a big thing for me.
You know, like being nominated
to the American Grammys
with an album that is full in Spanish.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The whole album, that's a big deal.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
It's great.
- That's beautiful.
I feel happy.
I wanna perform.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's my dream to go there, perform,
and taking the Grammy with me
and taking to Colombia, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For my Latino community.
That would be amazing.
- You know what's funny
is you just reminded me of something.
That's always my goal.
I always tell God, I'm like,
I don't care if I win, but
I really wanna perform.
I love performing.
- [Maluma] Yeah.
- Because I feel like that's
the best way to sell yourself
to an audience that
might not know you yet.
- I know, yeah.
- Is the performance part.
- Yeah, that's my favorite part.
That's what I love the most.
Going, perform, have fun.
See my friends, some colleagues, you know.
It's a great night.
Let's see what happens in this awards.
But if you guys are watching me right now,
please vote for me.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Absolutely, absolutely.
I will vote for you, I'm a voter.
Okay, be sure to check
out Maluma's latest album.
It's called "Don Juan," it's out now.